another item that emerged yesterday i
got a copy of court filing and let me
let me make this as simple as possible
there's an effort
to amend the complaint that was filed
against antonio brown in florida last
year
alleging sexual assault and rape the
plaintiff in that case
brittany taylor wants to add a claim for
punitive damages now i'm surprised there
wasn't a claim
for punitive damages from the start
because in any type of a case where
there
is an allegation of intentional
misconduct directed by one person to
another a civil lawsuit
punitive damages are sought because the
idea is you have somebody who did
something
deliberately and intentionally they
shouldn't have done it's not just enough
to compensate the victim you must punish
the perpetrator in order
to send a message to anyone out there
that this kind of behavior will not be
tolerated in the civilized society
that's what punitive damages do
they typically are always included they
haven't been included in this case
there's an effort to add it it surely
will be permitted it doesn't change the
allegations it just is a different
claim that's being attached to the
claims already made
but what this does this document and the
affidavit attached to it it's a vehicle
for reminding everyone that antonio
brown is facing some pretty
serious allegations an allegation of
sexual assault with some graphic details
we've written about it at
profootballtalk.com you can see it there
and an allegation of rape and in her
affidavit the last line of it she makes
it clear
he raped me again that's her allegation
but when we considered the nfl took no
action
on that specific claim and let him come
back
this lawsuit rolls forward and there's a
finding by a jury in florida that he did
this
doesn't matter whether it's criminal or
civil it doesn't matter whether the
standard is proof beyond a reasonable
doubt as it would be in a criminal case
or preponderance of the evidence 5149
you know just believe the victim a
little bit more than you believe
antonio brown doesn't matter what the
standard is if a jury
in florida finds that brown did it the
nfl
is going to be scraping egg off of its
face
for not coming to the same conclusion
before
the jury came to that conclusion so
there's a there's a pr
nightmare percolating out there for the
nfl depending upon how this case turns
out
yes i mean no doubt i i mean mike
to me when i saw this yesterday
the first thing i thought of is kind of
how you started it off was this more of
just like uh
hey i mean her you know
the young woman and then her
representative representation
was this just like wait you guys
nobody's gonna talk it's antonio brown
and tom brady it's cool oh yeah hey
they're back together
and this was just out there for a
warning to be like are you guys serious
you're all everybody's celebrating this
has everybody forgot about this aspect
i mean i feel like that's what it was
done to a degree like almost like
they're shocked he got back in the
league and now they're reminding
everybody
you know what what's this person may or
may be not like i mean
hey tampa's gonna have to deal with this
talk i don't know what else to say you
signed him you wanted to listen to brady
and company all that
antonio brown has four pages of issues
over the last five years
i mean it's a laundry list of issues so
you know like we've talked about you you
deal with that kind of thing it's going
to get on you too a little bit and
i don't know where it goes but it is
certainly dangerous
you know for for the nfl and
yeah i mean the whole thing's crazy
antonio brown some of his actions are
crazy
you know even what you wrote on the
article too i don't necessarily
understand some of those things too
you know the young woman was mistreated
and then came back again
why though that's where i don't
understand too and i'm not trying to
judge or anything like that i'm just
saying
antonio brown's life's crazy the story's
crazy and i don't know where the hell
this goes
yeah i mean look victims sometimes are
caught in i know kind of tough style
and and it's it's a difficult
relationship and
um you know it doesn't make it right
just because she comes back oh you're
right
and tries to maintain a relationship
with antonio
business is better than that too you're
right i'm not trying
to blank check right i know let me say
this though yeah
if if the lawyers representing brittany
taylor when they
filed the lawsuit in september of 2019
deliberately held back the claim for
punitive damages thinking at some point
down the
road there will be a pr benefit to
to adding that that's that's genius
that's
legal genius now look it's not
done for an entirely proper purpose
you're trying to put pressure on the guy
you're trying to remind people that this
guy did some things according to your
client
that are heinous and awful and
definitely not something that should be
tolerated by a civilized society but
at the same time they had a legitimate
way to remind everyone of the claims
made against antonio brown it's
legitimate because it wasn't part of the
case
they're trying to make it part of the
case and now we're all reminded of it so
you know regardless maybe we all needed
a reminder maybe the nfl needed a
reminder maybe the buccaneers needed a
reminder
as to what this guy is facing while he's
still
eligible to play in the national
football league we'll see how that all
plays out
the case is technically still scheduled
for trial next month
i'd be stunned if it goes forward next
month they have a lot of work to do they
have to do the entire discovery process
which is
questioning people under oath and
getting documents there's no way this
thing's going to be ready for trial next
month which is good news for antonio
brown
because it won't derail his 2020 season
it could affect him in 2021
but not this year hi i'm mike tarico and
thanks for watching
make sure to hit subscribe for the
latest news and highlights
from nbc sports